Toni wrote in, Tony says, Hey David, which
drugs do you think should be legalized or
decriminalized?
So number one, it's good that you're making
the distinction between legalized and decriminalized
because legalization and decriminalization,
uh, are, are very different things.
And also it's important to distinguish between
trafficking and personal use.
Okay.
So let's go in order.
All drug use and drug possession for personal
amounts should be decriminalized, period.
Uh, legalization.
Absolutely for marijuana and for other drugs.
I'm open to discussion you.
I believe it's Denver.
That's testing, uh, legalizing, uh, mushrooms
as an example.
I have less of a fixed opinion about the legalization
of some drugs.
I've not seen good reasons to legalize recreational
cocaine or heroin for example.
I'm very clear that possessing cocaine or
heroin for personal use should not be a crime.
Using cocaine or heroin should not be a crime.
Uh, but the recreational legalization of cocaine
and heroin, I just, I've not seen a good argument
for that and I'm willing to have my mind change.
Now this gets us to a really important element
of this debate that a lot of people miss.
A lot of people seem not to understand that
when you talk about legalization or decriminalization
of any drug, uh, you're not talking about
it being legal to be trafficking in those
drugs.
10 pounds of marijuana or a kilo of Coke or
whatever.
Whether you decriminalize or legalize, that
is likely still going to be criminal.
And when you think about it, alcohol is legal
recreationally.
Cigarettes are legal recreationally.
It is still against the law to traffic and
alcohol or cigarettes without doing it, you
know, on the record as a business in the way
that the, the guidelines say that you should,
you can have that debate.
And I'm, I'm glad to have it.
Uh, but it's important to understand and I
think that there are a lot of bad faith actors
on the anti decriminalization.
Anti legalization tends to be the political
right in the United States who either are
misunderstanding or they are deliberately
conflating the decriminalization or legalization
of the trafficking of drugs versus legalization
and decriminalization of amounts for personal
use.
And these are very, very different conversations.
So my question to you today is, what is the
strongest argument for recreational legalization
of drugs like cocaine and heroin?
I am 110% on board with marijuana.
Uh, I would sooner make cigarettes illegal
than say that marijuana should remain criminal
for use and possession.
Uh, but I, I simply have not seen a good case
made for why there should be recreational,
illegal cocaine or heroin.
But if you've got a good argument to make
along those lines, by all means get in touch
and then we can talk about it.